Politicians in a big, complex, sophisticated I.T. project?
Oh, that's going to be a disaster waiting to happen.
Not necessarily.
There is a precedent for technology-enabled service
that has been initiated by politicians in multiple countries
and has been hugely successful:
national lotteries.
Let's take Britain as an example.
Our government didn't design the national lottery,
it didn't fund the national lottery, it doesn't operate the national lottery.
It simply passed the National Lottery Act and this is what followed.
This act defines what a national lottery will look like.
It specifies certain benefits
that the state can uniquely bestow on the operators.
And it puts some obligations on those operators.
In terms of spreading gambling activity to the masses,
this was an unqualified success.
But let's suppose that our aim
is to bring new economic activity to the base of the pyramid.
Could we use the same model?
I believe we could.
So imagine that policymakers outlined a facility.
Let's call it national e-markets, NEMs for short.
Think of it as a regulated public utility.
So it's on a par with the water supply or the road network.
And it's a series of markets for low-level trade
that can be fulfilled by a person or a small company.
And government has certain benefits
it can uniquely bestow on these markets.
It's about public spending going through these markets
to buy public services at the local level.
It's about interfacing these markets
direct into the highest official channels in the land.
It's about enshrining government's role as a publicist for these markets.
It's about deregulating some sectors
so that local people can enter them.
So, taxi journeys might be one example.
And there are certain obligations that should go with those benefits
to be placed on the operators,
and the key one is, of course,
that the operators pay for everything,
including all the interfacing into the public sector.
So imagine that the operators make their return
by building a percentage markup into each transaction.
Imagine that there's a concession period
defined of maybe 15 years
in which they can take all these benefits and run with them.
And imagine that the consortia who bid to run it are told,
whoever comes in at the lowest percentage markup on each transaction
to fund the whole thing
will get the deal.
So government then exits the frame.
This is now in the hands of the consortium.
Either they are going to unlock an awful lot of economic opportunity
and make a percentage on all of it
or it's all going to crash and burn,
which is tough on their shareholders.
It doesn't bother the taxpayer necessarily.
And there would be no constraints on alternative markets.
So this would just be one more choice
among millions of Internet forums.
But it could be very different,
because having access to those state-backed facilities
could incentivize this consortium
to seriously invest in the service.
Because they would have to get a lot of these small transactions going
to start making their return.
So we're talking about sectors like home hair care,
the hire of toys, farm work,
hire of clothes even, meals delivered to your door,
services for tourists, home care.
This would be a world of very small trades, but very well-informed,
because national e-markets will deliver data.
So this is a local person
potentially deciding whether to enter the babysitting market.
And they might be aware that they would have to fund vetting and training
if they wanted to go into that market.
They'd have to do assessment interviews with local parents
who wanted a pool of babysitters.
Is it worth their while?
Should they be looking at other sectors?
Should they be moving to another part of the country
where there's a shortage of babysitters?
This kind of data can become routine.
And this data can be used by investors.
So if there's a problem with a shortage of babysitters in some parts of the country
and the problem is nobody can afford the vetting and training,
an investor can pay for it
and the system will tithe back the enhanced earnings of the individuals
for maybe the next two years.
This is a world of atomized capitalism.
So it's small trades by small people,
but it's very informed, safe, convenient, low-overhead and immediate.
Some rough research suggests this could unlock
around 100 million pounds' worth a day of new economic activity
in a country the size of the U.K.
Does that sound improbable to you?
That's what a lot of people said about turbo trading
in financial exchanges 20 years ago.
Do not underestimate the transformative power
of truly modern markets.
Thank you.
(Applause)